nous sommes tous ici ce soir réunis pour
partager des idées partager notre
perception du monde car les idées même
si ça peut faire très cliché de le dire
les idées peuvent véritablement changer
le monde
pas toutes certaines idées on m'a dit
que des produits des services qui ont
contribué à construire le monde dans
lequel nous sommes
je voulais dit pas tout les idées on
voit beaucoup de choses sur comment est
ce qu'on peut avoir des idées
comment développer la créativité
comment transmettre nos idées mais
qu'est ce qui donne une force à nos
idées parce que pour changer le monde
il faut une force on a vu des petites
idées avoir une grande force et des
grandes idées rarement survivre à
l'heure de l'apéro qui vont s'évaporer
très rapidement la force d'une idée ça
va être la capacité à déclencher un
potentiel d'action comment est-ce que
notre cerveau créer de la valeur et
prend ses décisions
vous ne voyez là présent vous m'entendez
et pourtant
est ce que je suis réel
tout n'est que perception certes tout
n'est que perception pour notre cerveau
mais tout n'est que représentation pour
notre conscience une illusion pour
comprendre ça il faut replacer le
cerveau à sa juste place et la juste
place de notre cerveau c'est entre nos
deux oreilles juste des régions quand on
a dit ça imaginez bien quand même notre
cerveau est dans notre boîte crânienne
d'accord il baigne dans un liquide
céphalo rachidien enveloppés dans des
méninges qui le protège ensuite il ya de
l'os ensuite il ya de la boue j'en
prends même certains qui ont rajouté des
cheveux par dessus bizarre l'accord donc
imaginez bien et on est bien d'accord là
dessus c'est que le cerveau n'a aucune
prise de contact avec le monde réel il
n'a aucune idée à ce à quoi ressemble le
monde réel
la seule chose que personne observant ce
sont des signaux électriques envoyées
par nos sens par notre perception
ensuite notre cerveau doit décoder ces
signaux électriques et sans donner une
représentation mais c'est une
représentation qui lui appartient on ne
sait pas quoi ressemble le monde réel
enfin une petite expérience
regardez là regardez vous les uns les
autres observez la pièce est repéré tous
les éléments rouge se donnent quelques
instants c'est bon c'est pratique la
couleur n'est ce pas ça paraît plus
facilement d'identifier des éléments
dans notre environnement mais la couleur
n'existe pas dans le monde réel la
couleur n'existe pas c'est une pure
traduction de notre cerveau dans le
monde réel ce qui existe ce sont des
ondes lumineuses à différentes
fréquences mais pour que notre cerveau
soit capable de mieux traiter ces
éléments là il
créer un code couleur tout n'est que
perception rapidement pourquoi est ce
que le cerveau a fait ça faut juste
imaginer que le cerveau s'est développée
à travers des centaines des dizaines de
millions d'années voire des centaines
avant que l'espèce humaine soit
considérée comme humaines pour répondre
à trois choses survivre se nourrir se
reproduire maintenant imaginez si vous
voyez en noir et blanc et vous êtes au
pied d'un cerisier essayer de repérer
les cerises vous allez finir par y
arriver mais vous allez passer plus de
temps et qui dit plus de temps à
s'exposer au danger surtout à l'époque
moins de chances de survivre ce que je
vous faire comprendre c'est que d'un
côté il ya les perceptions de l'autre
côté il ya la représentation de
perception en faire une autre expérience
maintenant je vais vous demander de
fermer les yeux dans n'ayez pas peur il
ya pas de piège vous pouvez fermer les
yeux ok maintenant replacer dans
l'espace les yeux fermés ce que vous
avez perçu en rouge tous les éléments
roche-posay repéré qu'est pas très
compliqué jusque là tout va bien
maintenant tout en gardant les yeux
fermés qui peut me dire combien j'ai de
grille d'aération dans le dos beaucoup
plus compliqué vous verrez ouvert les
yeux
pourquoi est-ce que c'est plus compliqué
c'est parce que certes vous avez perçu
des choses mais tout n'a pas été porté à
votre conscience
pourtant les grilles à son juste là
dernièrement depuis tout à l'heure votre
cerveau traite cette information
inévitablement votre cerveau aperçu ces
grilles mais n'a pas envoyé
l'information votre conscience en fait
notre cerveau perçoit des centaines de
milliers d'informations par seconde
mais ils vont m'envoyer à notre cerveau
qu au grand maximum une quarantaine et
c'est sur ces 40 information là que vous
allez vous construire une représentation
du monde ça ne veut pas dire qu'il est
réel ok
partant de ça on comprend maintenant
comment est ce qu'on perçoit
l'environnement et comment on s'en crée
une représentation mais à aucun moment
ça ne donne une idée sur la force d'une
idée sur la force d'un produit sur la
force d'un service c'est pas le tout de
le percevoir les idées qu'on partage
ensemble on les perçoit on s'en crée une
représentation mais encore une fois de
plus l oms où elles n'ont pas une force
derrière a déclenché le potentiel
d'action est ce que vous êtes capable de
vous rappeler quand vous avez pris la
décision de venir à cette aide
tout le monde se rappelle bien de ce
moment ok est ce que vous êtes capable
maintenant de vous rappeler des raisons
qu'est-ce qui a fait que les raisons
étaient suffisamment bonne suffisamment
forte pour pouvoir venir ici
normalement ça c'est simple de s'en
rappeler et à ce moment là normalement
vous êtes persuadé d'avoir pris votre
décision
consciemment volontairement en ayant
pesé le pour et le contre
profitez encore un petit peu de cette
illusion
parce que ça n'est qu'une illusion pas
plus tard que le mois dernier
deux chercheurs john coyne roberts et
johan persson ont publié les résultats
d'une étude ou en laboratoire ils ont
passé un sujet sous scanner et the
observer l'activité cérébrale de sujets
en observant son activité cérébrale
il était capable de prédire 11 secondes
avant la décision d'un individu avant
qu'ils en aient conscience 11 secondes
avant qui prend les décisions
c'est dérangeant en fait on n'est pas à
l'origine de nos décisions
quand je dis ça c'est vrai et c'est faux
on ne peut pas dissocier un sujet de sa
conscience ok mais par contre ce qu'on
peut dissocier c'est le traitement
inconscient des perception et la
représentation consciente qu'il s'en
fait et en l'occurrence on ne prend pas
de décisions de façon consciente
ce n'est qu'une illusion c'est le
système de perception c'est le
traitement inconscient des données de
perception qui vont créer une force
notre cerveau va prendre une décision
par rapport à cette force et l'angoissé
à la conscience et la conscience va
ensuite rationaliser la décision de
notre cerveau tout en ayant l'illusion
d'être à l'origine de sa décision
ce qui est important de comprendre là
dedans c'est que du coup ce n'est pas en
argumentant son étang ce n'est pas en
étant logique qu'on arrive à amener la
force d'une diffusion
on le voit bien si on était rationnel il
n'y aurait pas de fumeurs à la sortie
des biocoop
le fumeur a toujours toutes les bonnes
raisons de fumée et de se dire non il
faut que j'arrête
demain j'arrête alors je te promets
demain j'arrête le fumeurs fument pour
se détendre ou pour se donner du courage
il rationalise les décisions de son
cerveau et ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que en rationalisant il est pas
forcément rationnelle et vous pourrez
mettre toute l'énergie que vous voulez a
déployé une idée sur sa logique sur son
bien-fondé
sur sa raison c'est pas pour autant que
vous lui donnerez de la force
maintenant qu'est ce qui donne de la
force et des et bien c'est pas dans
l'illusion consciente qu'on a c'est pas
dans la logique c'est pas dans la raison
c'est dans nos perceptions et c'est en
modifiant le système de perception qu'on
va modifier la prise de décision et
ensuite on laissera gentiment la
conscience rationaliser cette
modification et laisser croire aux
sujets consciemment qu'il a pris sa
décision
en fait toutes nos perceptions parts au
plus profond de notre cerveau dans une
autre qu'on appelle le système limbique
à c'est une zone qui est importante pour
beaucoup beaucoup de choses régulation
du comportement régulation des émotions
mémorisation etc etc etc
c'est vraiment une zone très importante
dans le traitement de nos perceptions le
système limbique schématiquement il se
pose une question assez simple il ya le
flux de perception qui arrive à lui et à
chaque flux de perception et bien la
perception est dit est ce que ceci est
bon ou pas pour moi schématiquement
ghana gore et pas un petit bonhomme qui
est là il ya deux réponses possibles
oui ou non quand quelque chose n'est pas
bon que notre système limbique juge que
cette perception débat bonne pour nous à
ce moment là il va activer un circuit qu
on appelle le circuit de la version est
en gros quand ce circuit s'activent on
va produire du cortisol et
potentiellement de l'adrénaline et on
déteste
le cortisol on déteste ça en fait la
nature loin d'être stupide c'est 10 mai
si un individu à chaque fois qu'il est
en danger déclenché de cortisol moi ce
que je veux c'est que l'individu puisse
survivre
donc je n'ai pas envie qu'il aille se
mettre en danger ou alors qu'il reste
insensible aux dangers donc je vais
faire en sorte qu'ils détestent le
cortisol et ils y arrivent très bien on
est totalement à bercy au cortisone et
tout ce qu'on va faire dans la vie c'est
de chercher à éviter le cortisol
on va éviter de se mettre en danger ça
produit des états émotionnels
grosso modo entre en fonction du taux de
production et de sa durabilité
on va passer par des d'émotionnel qui
vont de la grosse frayeur à la peur à l'
angoisse à l'anxiété au souci etc etc
quand je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai
rarement croisé quelqu'un dans la rue
hyper flipper et on lui dit ça va one
chez hyper peur c'est génial non même
ces même bizarre amis mais on déteste ça
de l'autre côté
soyons un peu plus positif des fois les
choses sont bonnes pour nous et là quand
notre système limbique juge que quelque
chose est bon pour nous à ce moment là
il va déclencher ce qu'on appelle le
circuit de la récompense est le circuit
de la récompense
en l'occurrence il va déclencher
principalement de la dopamine et on
adore la dopamine
on adore ça la nature toujours pareil
s'est dit mais quand quelque chose est
bon pour notre survie
ça serait bien que je le motive à aller
chercher ça serait bien que je le motive
allait s'engager à prendre la décision
de faire aider dans ce cas là la nature
nous a rendus accros addict drogué à la
dopamine et même si j'étais un petit peu
plus de façon un peu plus large
on est accro à la dopamine à l'ocytocine
à la sérotonine et à l'endorphine et
retenez bien ça parce que c'est
fondamental absolument ce que vous
faites dans la vie
et quand je dis tous absolument tous
jusqu'à vous gratter l'oreille sont des
stratégies de notre cerveau pour
recevoir sa dose de dopamine d'ocytocine
de sérotonine ou d'endorphines en
fonction du contexte
nous sommes drogué totalement drogués
après on a tous notre petit délire petit
délire personnel
moi je suis un peu plus ce mélange
dopamine sérotonine d'eau doit être un
peu plus ce mélange dopamine ocytocine
en réalité on a besoin de tout le monde
a besoin de tout équilibré mais comme un
drogué on s'habitue à des seuils et plus
on en a plus on est nombreux
c'est ce qui nous pousse à aller le
chercher
elle est là la force d'une idée elle est
là la force d'un produit ou d'un service
c est ce que dans ce contexte si je
m'engage dans cette idée si je m'engage
à acheter ce produit si je m'engage à
vivre cette expérience là
quel est son potentiel a déclenché en
moi de la dopamine de l'ocytocine de la
sérotonine ou de l'endorphine plus la
capacité puis la potentialité de
déclenchement va être forte
puis notre cerveau va lui affecter une
valeur perçue importante et c'est ce qui
va déclencher
notre motivation notre envie à y aller
maintenant qu'on a compris qu'on vivait
dans un monde illusoire tout cas dans la
représentation que nous n'étions pas à
l'origine de nos décisions et que nous
sommes tous drogués vous êtes content
d'être venu
il faut réussir à intégrer ça dans vos
idées
schématiquement la dopamine c'est va se
déclencher lorsqu on se fixe des
objectifs ou lorsqu on les atteint la
dopamine va également se déclencher
lorsque nous pouvons satisfaire à des
besoins physiologiques comme boire ou
manger par exemple où va également se
déclenche et lorsqu'on va trouver une
stratégie qui nous permet d'éviter un
danger et donc d'éviter de produire du
cortisol l'ocytocine c'est un
neurotransmetteur très important pour
nous qui nous pousse à vivre en
communauté
c'est celle qui crée le lien entre nous
la nature cet aperçu qu'on avait
beaucoup plus de chances de survivre si
on était tous ensemble
donc il fallait nous motiver être
ensemble
donc à nous a rendus accros à
l'ocytocine et ont produit l'ocytocine
lorsqu'on crée du lien entre les gens
là maintenant tous ensemble j'ai
l'immense plaisir de vous dire que nous
partageons ensemble de l'eau siée
dossier moi je partage autre chose là le
prochain
la sérotonine un neurotransmetteur de
lego par excellence le mois je quant au
centre de l'attention
tous vos regards braqués que je le
veuille ou non
produit en moi de la sérotonine on
pourrait dire avec nos valeurs actuelles
que c'est un petit peu si on peut le
faire taire un petit peu l'égo pourtant
il est fondamental c'est grâce également
à la sérotonine qu'on ressent un
sentiment de bonheur et je suis très
heureux d'être avec vous le dernier
l'endorphine l'endorphine va se produire
moins évident à produire dans un
contexte d'une idée ça se produit quand
on a fini de faire une grosse activité
physique course à pied vélo
bon si vous voulez faire passer des
idées éviter de faire courir un marathon
à quelqu'un vous aurez un petit peu de
mal mais par contre ça va également se
produire à travers leur aise lorsqu on
rigole vraiment au projet de
l'endorphine ou alors après une grosse
frayeur
c'est pour ça qu'on est accro qu'on peut
tomber
accro au sport extrême ce sont les
contextes de production de l'a2 dopamine
ocytocine sérotonine est endormi pour
que vous puissiez réussir à intégrer ça
chacun va avoir ses propres
représentations du monde
chacun va avoir ses propres stratégies
de production de ce que j'appelle la
dose dopamine aussitôt site 0 tony des
endorphines
donc avant de même de vouloir véhiculer
une idée avant même de vouloir vendre un
produit avant même de pouvoir faire
vivre une expérience à quelqu'un
observez observer la personne observé ce
qu'elle fait observer quelles sont ses
stratégies à elle de production si vous
savez comprendre si vous savez vous dire
tiens quand cette personne là veut
partir d'un tel engagement ou dans telle
décision regardez ce qui se déclenchait
est ce que c'est de la dopamine est ce
que c'est la sérotonine est ce que c'est
l'endorphine une fois que vous avez
compris ça vous l'intégrer à vos idées
et je vous promets sincèrement qu'en
sachant créé
une belle illusion cohérente logique
mais que vous sachez également créé des
contextes de production de la dose vos
idées on savoir se répandre bien au delà
de vos espérances
merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]